Wedbush Securities analyst Michael  Pachter indicated to fortune that star  wars battlefront has sold 12 million  copies and generated 660 million dollars  in revenue tactus estimate was backed up  by Pacific Crest Securities analyst Evan  Wilson who said the battlefront her soul  to 13 million copies since launch Wilson  added that the majority of sales came  before the release of star wars the  force awakens EA has not confirmed any  official numbers although the company  did claim that battlefront broke records  at launch in November the publisher also  predicted that the game would ship 13  million copies by March 31 of this year  according to NPD data battlefront with  the number three game in the US during  november it was beaten by fallout 4 and  call of duty black ops 3 let me know  what you think of star wars battlefront  down in the comment section and stay  tuned to gamespot for more battlefront  news and everything else that matters in  gaming